his show prodigal son on tuesdays at
nine eastern on fox season two premiered
this past week but uh
we have enjoyed his work in so many
great uh tv shows and films
uh certainly back uh in the day stand
and deliver
la bamba and so much more he is lou
diamond phillips here on the rich eisen
show how are you lou
i am great rich thank you so much for
having me no thanks for coming on the
show let's let's uh
normally i can look at somebody's
hometown and where they were born and
try and figure out what sports team they
might be affiliated with or or love but
but you were you were born on a naval
base in the philippines is that right
lou i was indeed uh but i grew up
in mostly in texas okay so the cowboys
were my team of choice for the longest
time
but after having four daughters i'm
afraid i've fallen off sports dad
[Laughter]
okay so now let's talk about back in the
day uh are we talking ab like
like how how far back cowboys are we
talking about for you
oh my gosh uh with
uh we're talking seventies eighties
cowboys you know
uh uh starback is that what you're
talking about you're talking about roger
starback back in the day and and those
hundred percent right yes roger saw back
uh uh
and you know something i shared with my
dad who was also in the military so yeah
every every sunday we were in front of
the tube
uh and and uh unfortunately you know
what i mean like
like a lot of old guys like oh there's
there's no crew like the old crew
you know sure of course you know no no
doubt about that so
because again i i i'm i'm a lead pipe
wielding professional even though we
just met so i looked up uh
much of your history and your
filmography so to have appeared in an
episode of dallas
even for a split second at the very part
of beginning of your career that had to
be pretty big then
since uh that oh it was huge i mean that
was that was
absolutely one of my first jobs and it
was uh the the moment where
you know i thought wow i've i've arrived
you know i'm
i'm working with you know linda sue and
on a nationally televised
you know show and uh uh it just became
um
uh uh a side post that i was on
i was on the right path certainly yeah i
mean i remember that show and how you
saw texas stadium in the open you know
the flyover you they would look into the
stadium and that just
always used to get me so excited but for
everybody spoiler alert you were not the
one who shot j.r ewing
correct lou that was not just to be
clear that was not me
okay it's done you so we can move on so
then how did you
first get uh the gig uh your breakout
role with la bamba what how did that go
down
for you oh my goodness that you know i
mean that it's kind of a
lightning and a bottle legend now but uh
i i was
working in the texas film industry i was
doing a lot of you know small gigs like
the one on dallas
uh and they actually did a national
talent search to find richie and came to
dallas texas for one day
uh i was put on videotape and flown out
to hollywood a couple of weeks later
where you know i won the screen test uh
and the rest is history i i was actually
literally
still living in texas working as a local
actor when uh they quote unquote
discovered me there
so you kind of like hit the lottery is
what you're saying
uh in a way no it's huge it's huge i
mean
uh the the the the funny thing is i've
taught acting uh
you know off and on for a number of
years right and everybody's going
well how do you make it i said well you
know a big part of it is luck
you just have to be in the right place
at the right time and that was the case
for me
but that luck always comes with a great
deal of preparation
so i had to be ready to accept that role
when the opportunity came
but you know you cannot you really
cannot uh
control uh you know what comes down the
pike toward you you just you just have
to be ready for the chance when you
called off the bench
you know sure that's the you know and to
use another sports phrase
um that from branch ricky the great
general manager of the
brooklyn dodger days luck is the residue
of design
is the is the the great sports phrase so
obviously so how did you prepare
when you're when you know look look you
just got to take a chance i mean i got
my start
in um in television sending a a big
thick three-quarter inch tape to a
headhunter you know and putting a
first-class
postage on it to make sure it got there
right away and put it in the u.s mail
and espn found me i mean like i i felt
like i was struck by lightning
uh in that but how did you prepare for
for this role
for for such an open wide uh countrywide
casting
lou well i mean one you know once again
it it it's all about uh you know to
continue the sports analogy
you know you trained and you train you
train for that moment
when you know it it uh it happens i mean
what was it bruce lee says uh you know
i'm uh
i'm not afraid of the guy that can throw
a thousand kicks i'm afraid of the guy
that's practiced one kick a thousand
times that's right
so you know at that point you know in my
life i had a degree in theater
i was training film acting with uh adam
rourke i was teaching film acting
and all of that was a confluence that
came together
when i had the uh the audition of a
lifetime and you know there it was
so um do you sing karaoke
lou i do i do
and uh sadly enough there's plenty of
uh video footage out there on the
internet okay uh
uh most of it good i'm pretty happy
about that you should be
uh yeah i know that that that happens on
occasion so then when was the last time
you sang la bamba when was the last time
you actually did that
wow the last time i said la bamba yeah
what was the last time
uh probably you know what uh i had a
birthday party
for prodigal son there was a karaoke
night
uh bellamy young who's on the show and
michael sheen and i
yes all all are within a couple of weeks
of each other
and we threw a big karaoke party and
just to appease the
crew i think it's about to say appease
is a great word
because you must be just like really or
you can really ask me to say
you must be like really rich i mean i
can't i can't walk into a mexican
restaurant
with a mariachi band because i know it's
going to happen within four songs
within four song okay that's it's kind
of like name that tune that's amazing
lou diamond phillips here
and before we get to the to the here and
now uh just lingering uh in the past a
little bit
uh young guns i mean um you know that is
a tremendous movie with a tremendous
cast
what was it like to be uh with all
of those fellow actors at such a height
of so many different moments and careers
for everybody at such a young age what
was that like
uh well i have to say rich stepping on
to that set
i had done la bamba i had done stand and
deliver right
stepping on that set for me was the
moment where i realized i had arrived
you know la bomba was a negative pick up
through the studio it was a low budget
film
stand and deliver was a micro low budget
film and then suddenly i'm on a set with
amelia
peters and cooper sutherland and charlie
sheen and and
you know i thought okay that that's it
i'm the ethnic member of the brass pack
and uh and is there a safe for work
story
you could tell me a good safe for work
story
from from that safer work story
wow uh you know what emilio uh
uh is a massive prankster okay uh
the very first day of filming uh we all
got these fedex packages
that were supposedly from fox studios uh
that said hey you know here's what we
think of you thank you so much for being
a part of this
emilio had sent them and when you opened
it up it was a cow pie
so uh it was after that moment it was
on okay the practical jokes came fast
and furious after that
okay now here's a not safe for work
story go for it
no you don't got one i'm sure no i'm not
gonna
quite honestly back in the day thank
goodness tmg and camera folks didn't
exist i mean
a lot of us might have been very
embarrassed is it true that extras on
that film
were jon bon jovi and tom cruise is that
a true story
or is that uh is that false uh well
number one they weren't extras
but uh yeah cameos in this film
cameos okay absolutely true yeah tom
tom cruise is in the first one we
heavily made him up because he'd never
been shot before and he wanted to be
uh and that was in the first one and the
second one uh
uh john mon jovi got his sad card by
getting shot on camera uh
coming out of the pit no kidding so john
bon jovi
got his screen actors guild card by
getting shot
in a cameo in young guns that is a true
fact
and the beauty of it is john wanted to
hang around on set for a couple of weeks
to write the soundtrack he wanted to
soak up the ambiance he wanted to get
some first-hand experience
and then one night he's like hey let's
throw john in there and shoot him
no that happened
and so tom cruise at this point of his
career
had never been shot on camera before is
what you're saying like
like he's never had uh and and he was a
friend of emilio's from the uh uh the
outsider
yeah and he came to visit uh and was
hanging around and say and you know for
a goof said hey man let's shoot me
uh so they made him up so he was
virtually unrecognizable
but if you freeze frame uh the the uh
the big finale where you know emilio
pops out of the trunk at the end
one of the first guys he shoots is tom
that is unbelievable lou i mean that is
absolutely
remarkable lou diamond phillips here on
the rich hazard show you mentioned you
have four daughters have you shown
any of your uh early work to them have
you have you
gone back in the day with your the older
girls
have uh you know seen some of the some
of the work but i mean
uh when grayson bella and lily were
young they saw la bamba
it was so traumatic but i i haven't
shown uh indigo who's now 13
uh that film just yet so uh yeah that
that's an occupational hazard you know
you don't want to see your dad die
well no i understand that um i hear you
uh uh
let's let's talk about the here and now
as well uh before again we get to um
uh prodigal son you were fantastic in
goliath
um in the episodes that you were in that
show is
dynamite man um and i wonder what it was
like
on this i mean you've been on the set uh
with some
fellow uh thespians before you mentioned
edward james almost about billy bob
being in uh on screen with him lou what
was that like
well you know it's so funny man i'm at
the point in my career where
if an opportunity comes up and it's
somebody i want to work with right
i really don't even have to look at the
material it's like oh i'm gonna do a
couple of episodes with billy bob i
didn't even read it
you know right i said yes you know same
thing with 24 and working with kiefer
and dennis hoffman that first season
there there there are actors that i just
want to work with and and so
uh uh because part of the life
experience you know is is
uh you know one of the perks of it all
uh and
and uh i gotta say man i mean from an
artistic standpoint
working with billy bob you know knowing
that it was gonna be a brief
it was just wonderful and and his whole
approach to the work uh it's all about
the acting it's all about the story
it was you know it was just a gift and
uh
i i wish i could have done more but you
know i was i was happy to have what i
had
lou diamond phillips here on the rich
eisen show let's get to uh prodigal son
what attracted you to this show
to do it lou uh you know what's funny is
that you know i'm playing a police
lieutenant
and those are a dime a dozen in
procedurals and this role was so unique
and so original
and had so much going on not only in the
backstory but in the relationships that
he has with the other characters
that that was a very easy yes i was i
was
extremely happy to to be involved with
this and the fact that it's been so well
received that it's a hit
and uh people are loving the entire
ensemble
um it's you know and and now when i look
at it
it's crazy because we got you know
michael sheen we got tom payne we got
bellamy young
we we have a murderer's row of an
ensemble and you know catherine zeta
jones is joining us this year yeah
um i i really really just feel
incredibly fortunate
well again um thanks for joining me here
lou i've been a big fan of yours for
for many many years and i you know i
just as much as this show is about
sports is it it's about pop culture as
well and you've been in some incredible
films and television shows throughout
the years and i'd love to just keep
kicking it with you whenever you want to
you know promote anything or come back
on i appreciate the time i i'd love to
come back any time rich thanks for
having me you bet that's lou diamond
phillips at lou
d phillips on twitter check out prodigal
son tuesday's not eastern on fox right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here